what's your favorite movie uh one of
them is fresca trout and another mr.
Peabody and Sherman
my kids have seen a lot of cartoons on
the TV and in the movie theater my wife
and I loved animated films too when we
were growing up there was only one name
in animated movies Disney for about six
decades they were pretty much the only
game in town by the mid-90s Disney films
had started to follow a formula they
would take an old story at a few musical
numbers and voila Pocahontas Hercules
Mulan
but then something new happened in
animation Pixar reinvented how you make
an animated movie instead of drawing
characters you code them on a computer
which makes them come alive in 3d
instead of being flattened
two-dimensional I'm sure you remember
Pixar's first computer animated movie
Toy Story it was a smash not just cuz
the tech was cool but also because this
story was fresh it was just so vivid and
funny and the characters were original
this is Brad Bird he's a writer animator
and director they weren't doing the ten
songs and all that stuff that was
getting very standard in animation at
the time Pixar's first three films got
multiple Oscar nominations they grossed
over a billion dollars the studio was a
perfectly calibrated hit machine and
that's when they made a strange decision
they hired Brad he was coming off a big
project that tanked don't make me go
back there man don't make me go back and
it wasn't his first failure I got fired
from Disney and I was actually fired
from two of the first three jobs I held
but Pixar saw promise in Brad he came to
the studio with a bold vision for a new
film and he didn't recruit the star
teams who had created their earlier hits
instead he deliberately assembled a band
of Pixar's biggest misfits black sheep
scrunt I say pirate doesn't exactly
sound like a dream team but somehow the
movie they made together grossed over
600 million dollars won two Oscars and
was Pixar's biggest hit yet it was
incredible incredible the critics loved
it almost as much as my kids did
[Music]
I'm Adam grant and this is work life my
podcast with Ted I'm an organizational
psychologist I study how to make work
not suck in this show I'm inviting
myself inside the minds of some truly
unusual people cuz they've mastered
something I wish everyone knew about
work today shake ups and the value of
the outsiders inside your workplace
thanks to you bonobos for sponsoring
this episode
[Music]
what's the best time to shake things up
in most workplaces it happens when
you're struggling when the chips are
down you're desperate and you have
nothing to lose by taking some risks but
by then it's often too late you don't
have the resources to run bold
experiments the evidence suggests that
the best time to shake things up is
actually when you're doing well that's
when you have the time energy and
freedom to innovate but sadly research
shows that success often makes us
complacent experts call it the fat cat
syndrome think about a time when you've
been at the top of your game did you
really want to embrace something
radically different of course not
you probably became overconfident in
your recipe and resistant to try new
things
take Blockbuster Video at one point they
were apparently opening a new store
every 17 hours so they didn't see any
reason to buy a little mail-order
company called Netflix oops
one day the CEO of a successful company
gave me that line I hate but that's the
way we've always done it my answer
blockbuster blackberry porridge Toys R
Us do you want me to keep going so how
do you shake things up before it's too
late for that we're going to the movies
in 1999 Warner Brothers released the
first animated movie directed by Brad
Bird Iron Giant I remember being so
excited about it this is Brad's producer
John Walker it was the first big project
for both Brad and John an opening day
John went to see it in a big theater in
Times Square and there were three people
in there I went what the heck is going
on and so I spent the rest of the day
just hanging around in front of the
marquee and whenever anybody would come
by and look at the poster I'd go it's a
really good movie I'll buy your tickets
I gave I probably probably about like
ten people tickets to see it cuz there
was no one in the theaters it was empty
empty it was just such so I thought oh
that's it that's it that sets the end of
me I have the Iron Giant on my resume
and nothing more the film failed
commercially but it was wildly original
and the leaders at Pixar saw potential
there so Brad Bird and John Walker got
the call from two of the studio's
co-founders Edie Catmull and Steve Jobs
they go you know we'll bring this
bacteria in from the outside and see if
it grows in the petri dish no they were
actively choosing a guy to come up who
had just made a big flop Pixar was
founded on a disruptive vision their
leaders fervently believed it was never
too early to throw your own recipe out
the window Steve Jobs wanted to keep
raising the bar bigger hits longer run
times so we've picked a couple of
outsiders to drive a shake up they were
feeling like we're in danger of falling
into certain habits because we have the
same group that are doing things and
we're very proud of this group and this
group is very talented but we want to
shake things
and they felt like whatever I was going
to do it was gonna be different and so
they said okay well here can you guys do
it can you do it in half the time half
the money they gave the answer you'd
probably give if Steve Jobs had asked
you that question well sure we can just
you just say you can write and then you
try to go figure out how to do it so
Pixar hired John Walker and Brad Bird
Brad had been working on a new story for
an animated film it would be called The
Incredibles it was different than
anything Pixar had ever done everything
that the film was was all the things
that CG animation was then terrible at
it was full of humans which they were
the weakest thing in CG animation if you
look at humans circa that time Pixar
films had only had humans as minor
characters and they didn't look very
convincing to date Pixar's movies were
mostly filled with toys monsters and
talking bugs now Brad was pitching a
movie that would require animating a
whole family of not just humans humans
with superpowers it was full of water
and fire and wind and all this stuff
that CG animation was no good at doing
your hair it turns out hair was a real
problem prior to the Incredibles no one
had even bothered to code long hair
because it was just impossible in CG
animation it's almost like everybody
used a ton of hairspray before they got
filmed because the hair doesn't move
much and you know we were doing a film
were kind of it was part of violets
character violet is a member of The
Incredibles family a shy moody teenager
do you know what does anyone in this
family know about normal she was
supposed to spend a huge part of the
film covering her face with her long
black hair we'd seen these beautiful
tests producer John Walker and it was
like wow she's shaking her head and the
hair is flowing and it's gorgeous and
it's gonna be beautiful
but the tests were oversimplified the
hair moved right but kind of looked like
strips of rubber when it was time to do
the full computer animation
violets hair looked awful so John asked
what it would take to get it right and
he was shocked at the answer we can't
actually do the movie like that that
would take you know ten years and
technically does then why'd you show us
that I was gonna I'm trying to get
myself ready to go tell Brad that we're
gonna cut violets hair you can't do it
that's the character she's got to have
the hair as the film goes on she feels
enough growing self-assurance that she
pulls the hair out of her face her hair
had a story arc to do hair and water and
all these other new images correctly
Pixar execs guessed that the film could
cost half a billion dollars and take a
decade to make Brad needed some original
thinking so this unconventional director
went looking for a team of
unconventional recruits The Outsiders
among Pixar's insiders the black sheep
they're not always the smiling nastazya
steeple to work with sometimes they're a
little grumpy bred have you ever been a
black sheep yourself yeah yeah yes yeah
my family was kind of like the family
and Incredibles we had these dinners
where everybody vented and said what
they thought that's the attitude that I
kind of grew up in and I found very
quickly the world doesn't work that way
Brad searched Pixar's ranks for people
who were frustrated with the status quo
people who had risky ideas that had been
dismissed or overlooked you might have
one of those people on your team or
maybe you're the black sheep there's a
big impetus especially with success to
repeat what Evers worked before you know
if it ain't broke don't fix it
but I was looking for a bunch of people
that were kind of dissatisfied with the
way things were turns out Brad was onto
something
research shows that the kind of
frustration he harnessed scan fuel
creativity in other words the
curmudgeons on your team could be great
untapped resources I'm sure you've seen
companies hire external consultants or
executives to shake things up
but there's evidence that you don't have
to turn to outside hires you can go to
the black sheep already working within
the company consider one study that was
done at a company that makes oil
drilling equipment supervisors evaluated
how often employees brought new and
innovative ideas to the table
the employers who were rated the most
creative were the ones who felt
dissatisfied with their jobs their
frustration with problems motivated them
to develop fresh solutions but
dissatisfaction didn't always lead to
creativity it only helped when people
felt committed to the company and had
access to the feedback and support they
needed when you ignore them disgruntled
people channel their frustration and
unproductive or even counterproductive
directions if you're aware they're out
there though and you really listen to
them they can become your allies they
always say innovation is the pirate ship
that sails into the Yacht Club nobody
likes it but then they appreciate it
later this is Lisa Bodell she spent part
of her career in advertising and
startups and I came there to do really
great motivating inspiring things and I
was spending my day just managing
processes and procedures and crap
Lisa got fed up with the dozens of
meaningless tasks that to find so many
work environments so she started a
company called future think to help
organizations shake up the status quo
and ideally walk away with things that
will help you simplify your work and
your life to get you moving forward and
what I thought we could do is go through
about I don't know 500 PowerPoint slides
does that work for you all know her big
breakthrough came when she was giving a
talk to a few dozen executives at a
manufacturing company I realized quickly
that these people didn't give a crap
about what I was talking about and so I
called a break and I said listen I'm
gonna shake things up she looked at all
these board executives and told them to
kill their own company I challenged each
of those groups to identify who their
number-one competitor was and then I
said pretend you're that competition
pretend you have that hat on I want you
to put yourself out of business I mean
just the room that on fire they were so
excited because I gave them permission
to talk about the things that were
literally verboten it was a mindset
shift as well as a business
strategy shift when I heard about the
exercise I was expecting a room full of
complaints and cynicism then I watched
it happen and I have never seen a more
energized group of leaders in my life
really what it does is give people a
framework and permission to start
attacking things that aren't working and
that that's what's energizing to people
is that they they don't know the
difference at them between being in a
groove and being in a rut and most
people when you talk about complacency
are in a rut and until you talk to them
about what do you wish you could change
why are you frustrated they get pumped
up one thing that's always fascinated me
about this exercise is how different it
would be if you ran it as save the
company
and I was interested in hearing sort of
what led you to the boldness of killing
the company rather than then saving the
company save means safe and preserve you
know I think of a life preserver
how can we keep what we have safe versus
how can we get rid of what we have and
do things better
it's permission to admit that things
might not be right so you can look at
what's not working and make space for
things that are if you were asked to
kill your company where would you start
you might begin the way Lisa does gather
some people together to give their
frustration a voice put them on offense
not defense by asking them to attack the
problems they see and then invite them
to run with their best ideas
Lisa's approach has worked in all kinds
of environments banks tech companies
city governments schools and Brad Bird
did his own version of it at Pixar Pixar
kind of invented a lot of the stuff that
that now everyone takes for granted I
mean they were the best in the world at
it those methods weren't going to work
for our film
Brad challenged the black sheep to try
different solutions to their toughest
animation problems like violets hair
they don't want to do something the way
that it's always been done for every 20
people that say this is how you do it
there's usually one person going you
don't have to do it that way there's
another way that you could do it but
there was one problem that neither Brad
nor John Walker had anticipated there
were different rooms they were doing
different
the technical people had been unleashed
to build all these new tools but the
creative people didn't really understand
how to use them something would go wrong
an email would come from one side going
hey your simulator is broken over to the
people that were building simulator and
the similar guys would write back no no
no no it's operator error and he would
would go back and forth like that we go
over gosh this is not working Brad and
John started listening to the people on
the front lines and they suddenly
realized there was a simple solution to
their complex problem put the technical
people together with the animators in
the same rooms as soon as that started
to happen it was like magic because
somebody show them the problem and see
look what happens I do this and the hair
flies around the room and the guy's
building somebody goes well you gotta
hit f3 - seven and put this a little bit
of a code in there I didn't you know
that and they go no we didn't know that
you beautiful thing of when you go after
black sheep you say hey I'll give you a
crazy idea try that's kind of where they
want to go
so wait Brad does that mean you're just
trying to surround yourself constantly
with angry people no I mean I don't want
just disgruntled people there's plenty
of those and they don't do a damn thing
for anybody I want people who are
disgruntled because they have a better
way of doing things and they are having
trouble finding an avenue racing cars
that are just spinning their wheels in a
garage rather than racing you open that
garage and man those people take you
somewhere
[Music]
so you've got your team into satisfied
people you're ready for them to shake
things up now how do you get them all
innovating in the same direction more on
that after the break okay this is gonna
be a different kind of ad I've played a
personal role in selecting the sponsors
for this podcast because they all have
interesting cultures of their own today
we're going inside the workplace at
bonobos a few years ago Sam Gonzales was
on an all staff call at bonobos when the
top boss said something that took his
breath away she had said one of the
things in that conference call was that
we were going to embrace in our
marketing campaigns we were gonna really
start to think about gender identity for
Sam a guide in one of bonobos shops the
idea that a men's clothing brand was
gonna focus on gender identity wasn't
just exciting it was personal I'd worked
at bonobos for a little over a year
before I figured out the like I am trans
and I want a transition and that will
include for me and like letting everyone
that I work with know and everyone who
comes into my life know that you know
this is a part of who I am
Samet prepared for the worst what does
it mean to transition at work because I
had only heard horror stories but then
once I did I you know was proved 100
percent wrong people were super open
they were incredibly caring and
respectful and then just a few months
later Sam found himself on this
all-hands phone call Mickey on parole
then the co-president and now bonobos
CEO said the company was gonna start a
public conversation about gender
identity as soon as the call finished
Sam sent her an email I said you know I
don't know if you know this but I am
trans and I have transitioned up and
oboes and I've been here for a while and
you have no idea what this type of
representation means to someone like me
when I first got Sam's email I would to
be honest completely overwhelmed I think
I probably shed a tear or two
I'm Mickey on Braille I am the CEO of
bonobos for me it was very touching that
someone felt comfortable
enough to be able to tell me that
personal story think about how rare that
is for a junior employee to feel
comfortable emailing someone that high
up I almost never see it even though I
spend a lot of time encouraging senior
leaders to be open
yep ANOVA's Mickey wasn't just receptive
to new ideas from below she actively
encouraged them and I had talked a
little bit about in my email that I had
met Chris Moser and I think that he
would be a fantastic person for us to
highlight I mean the first thing I did I
forwarded it on to our production team
and I said Sam's just had this amazing
idea it was bringing Chris motor in and
shooting him in our clothes let's do it
Chris Moser was part of the American
men's duathlon team in 2016 that made
him the first openly transgender athlete
to compete for Team USA Chris was one of
the first people that I saw that made me
feel like being transit is a thing and
you can do it and you can transition and
you can be happy so Sam made a pitch for
bonobos to feature Chris in a commercial
for a men's clothing company to say
trans men are men and can be a part of
our campaign to me personally was it was
a big deal that's Chris a few months
later but no bows launched a commercial
that featured him it was sort of what I
was searching for when I was younger
like if I would have seen out trans men
being a part of men's campaigns being a
part of men's fashion magazines or
commercials on TV that are talking about
men and masculinity I think that my
trajectory would have been drastically
different as a person so Sam is you
reflect on this whole experience of
first transitioning at work and then
bring you on Chris as a spokesperson how
does that make you feel there's not
really a word to describe it I think
awesome is too small of a word awesome
is too small a word I like that and I
like the idea that big ideas can come
from anywhere in a company as long as
there's support at the top
bonobos makes great clothes that can fit
every guy ordering on their website is
easy this ship fast and if it doesn't
fit they want to know visit bonobos comm
enter promo code Ted a check out and get
20% off your first order
that's bonobos comm and promo code Ted
for 20% off when you're gathering a
group of people for a major shakeup how
do you motivate them your first instinct
is probably do inspire them we never
lost an American in space we're sure as
hell not going to lose one on my watch
failure is not enough
[Music]
you can do it if you're working with a
bunch of disgruntled black sheep
you'll feel especially compelled to
convey confidence show enthusiasm and
make sure they don't get discouraged by
the sheer difficulty of the task but if
you're Brad bird and you're making the
Incredibles you do the exact opposite
Brad told his team no one thought they
could pull it off that's the kind of
challenge that lights a fuse and Brad
and that's how he leads our teams
this is Nicole parody Grendel she's been
a producer at Pixar since the mid 90s
when Nicole joined The Incredibles team
they've been struggling with the
animation for about a year I was working
with the engineers who were trying to
figure out how to do the hair on the
cloth and they were saying it was
impossible Brad was asking for too much
and they just kept saying nope nope nope
we can't do it and they were trying and
the stuff they were producing look
terrible
we have these crew meetings once a week
so everyone's wandering in first thing
in the morning with their coffee piling
into this big theater that we have and
he gets up in front of this room of
people and he just starts yelling and
telling them they think we can't do this
they think we're too slow they think
we're not good enough I tell you we're
gonna do this you know and and people
love it I mean it's it's pep-rally
what Brad did by instinct is actually
backed by evidence if you want to
motivate black sheep give them a battle
to fight a particular kind of battle one
thing that is very effective is to find
a common enemy but the enemy doesn't
have to be a person it can be a mindset
it can be a presumption it can be a
system that doesn't want to change you
know it can even be something like a
trend in movies that is just making
movies stupider you can make that the
enemy and you can put it up in front of
people and say you know what I don't
like I don't like X and here's how I
think we can not do this thing that
everyone is doing and really
dazzle the audience and people like that
because you're putting them on the
pirate ship
you're not going with the well-funded
safe routes you're kind of striking your
sails in a storm and you're okay with it
that fires people up you know it fires
me up it sounds like in that moment
Brad was shaping how his team perceived
those outside of their team and
basically framed those individuals as
critics or naysayers this is Samir nur
Mohammed my colleague at Wharton he
studies what happens when were cast in
the role of underdog stories of
underdogs and favorites permeate
societies David versus Goliath
horatio alger Ivan the fool and in
Russian literature you see these
examples of underdogs going from rags to
riches or performing against others low
expectations across the world an
underdog isn't a kind of person it's a
mindset that can help you approach
problems the way black sheep do you can
position people as underdogs by telling
them they're not expected to succeed and
surprisingly the uphill battle is often
the one that people are most excited to
fight in a study with job seekers who
had faced discrimination in their
careers samir randomly assigned some of
them to tell a story about how they had
been underdogs against the odds it
almost doubled their chances of landing
a job in the following month you
actually experience more efficacy and
more confidence to do well and it leads
to higher performance in another study
Samir had people fill out a survey about
their negotiating style then he told
them that based on their results he'd
calculated the probability of their
success in the negotiation he told some
participants they were the favorites
some they were evenly matched and told
others that they were the underdogs the
underdog actually ended up reaching the
more creative solution people who were
told that they couldn't succeed actually
ended up performing better and the
reason for this is that they essentially
wanted to prove the researchers wrong
the favorites had nothing to prove they
got complacent the underdogs were driven
to show they'd been misjudged which
happens in all kinds of jobs even
Michael Jordan motivated himself this
way even in his Hall of Fame induction
speech
when the world came out to celebrate
with him he was calling out his school
coach who chose another player over him
and how this fueled his motivation to
prove them wrong what's remarkable is
that Jordan was talking about being
underestimated after being universally
recognized as not only the greatest
basketball player ever but as one of the
greatest athletes of all time
Jordan was still constructing that
perception of being underestimated and
using that as motivation to prove others
wrong but before you start cutting down
all your colleagues in the name of
motivation keep in mind that there's a
wrong way to do it this doesn't mean you
go around the workplace telling everyone
that they can't succeed that's not the
way to instill this motivation as a
person in this position who's seen as an
underdog you have to feel like you have
the capabilities to succeed for the
underdog approach to work the low
expectations need to come from the right
messenger a natural adversary when a
really credible person tells you you
can't succeed in some sense you
basically internalize those expectations
your confidence drops you actually
believe them and you don't perform as
successfully on the other hand when you
receive low expectations from someone
who's not seen as credible you perceive
them as really in competent or not
knowledgeable about either the domain
that you're performing in or your own
abilities this is what sparks that
desire to prove others wrong so if
you're rallying salespeople you can
emphasize that R&D doesn't think they
can hit their targets and if you're
trying to motivate technical or creative
people you can tell them they're being
doubted by a bunch of suits that's what
those black sheep probably are looking
for is an opportunity to show what they
can do Pixar producer Nicole Grindle saw
Brad's underdog gambit pay off the black
sheep at the studio felt the naysayers
had no business judging their abilities
or the new animation techniques they
were about to invent the idea that we're
proving folks wrong I think is the prime
motivator I mean of course we want to
make a great film and a great story and
that's a given but proving that you know
proven to the man that we're better than
they think we are that's that's exciting
and that's what folks in this industry
live to do is you know
act in that kind of a story the last
step for energizing your shakeup team is
to calibrate the degree of difficulty
how challenging should the goal be I
think you always have the impossible
task because basically to do really good
work is hard and if you're doing it
right you are kind of an underdog you
should be shooting for something that's
out of reach and maybe you don't hit it
but at the end of it if you are reaching
for something that's beyond your reach
you're probably going to extend your
reach from your previous work in
psychology we call that kind of reach
adjust manageable difficulty it's a
challenge that tests and stretches your
skills to the very edge of what you
think is possible it has to be tough but
it can't set you up for certain failure
either as Pixar producer John Walker
puts it sometimes you have to swim
upstream sometimes you have to swim
upstream but if you swim upstream too
long something is probably wrong okay I
came away from Pixar convinced that to
shake things up it can help to recruit
the people you least expect frustrated
people and listen to them then motivate
them by making them into underdogs
against the odds or a difficult enemy
but I was curious about whether this
could all work in a place that's the
total opposite of Pixar the ultimate
bureaucracy an environment where strict
orders are followed old traditions
crushed new technologies and creativity
isn't just not rewarded it's sometimes
actively punished recruit training where
a man is taught the basic skills for the
sea the US Navy he learns to be part of
the team he learns where he might fit in
a few years ago a military general told
me that if I wanted to understand
innovation in the Armed Forces
I had to talk to a junior naval officer
named Ben Coleman my grandfather was a
World War 2 aviator and my great-uncle
was an Air Force pilot who was shot down
for Vietnam and spent five years in the
Hanoi Hilton with John McCain and Jim
Stockdale and those stories infused my
upbringing and I just I wanted to be
leading carrier battle fleets against
whoever was attacking the United States
so I was surprised to hear Ben's
colleagues call him a black sheep a
rabble rouser a troublemaker
troublemaker is an amusing term for mean
I think my parents will get a kick out
of that do you think you are one though
or you became one in the Navy I think I
became a troublemaker in the sense of
challenging established wisdom then may
have been a sailor but he didn't start
out as a pirate I was in a fraternity
that was known for its parties but was
the guy doing risk management in the
outside making sure nothing too crazy
went down then became a naval aviator
just like the pilots and Top Gun their
call sons were maverick Iceman my
callsign was Professor Rick as had this
this habit of reading long books like
the American history of law and
listening to classical music when Ben
flew missions as a naval pilot he had a
huge amount of autonomy being a 27 year
old who's leading 265 million dollar
jets with you know four 500-pound bombs
this is an incredible amount of
responsibility on a daily basis
you were the on-scene commander but when
Ben came back from overseas deployment
he started getting frustrated frustrated
that people were getting rewarded based
on seniority
instead of performance frustrated that
people were getting promoted for
conformity instead of original thinking
frustrated that a field-tested combat
pilot couldn't even have a beer on a
Friday night without seeking approval
from a senior commander you know there's
five or six levels of approval even if
the first four people say yes
the only takes one beater to kill an
idea and so that becomes very
discouraging and you stop caring to some
extent so Ben wrote an essay for a
military news site he explained his
frustration and challenged the Navy to
start supporting and promoting junior
people with disruptive ideas piping up
like that is sort of not done in the
military
and I said some pretty intense if
unreflecting on it but it got the
attention of a lot of senior officials
who were a gas that I would write
something like this but some leaders
were open to Ben's perspective a Navy
admiral was setting up something called
a rapid innovation cell and he asked Ben
to direct it now to give you a sense for
how slowly the Navy adopts new
technologies some of their computers are
still running Windows 95 yet over the
next year
Ben's rapid innovation cells succeeded
in getting 3d printers installed on
ships they also tested a robot fish
affectionately named silent Nemo for
stealth underwater missions it looks
like a tuna in case you were wondering
been fuelled these advances with the
same strategy as we saw at Pixar his
first step was to recruit black sheep
many of them had been disciplined for
insubordination like one guy who was
fired from a nuclear submarine for
disobeying an order and ended up being
one of the key innovation catalysts how
did you find them and it was that a
signal that you were deliberately
looking for let me just find a bunch of
people who are pissed off yeah if you
had the guts and the willingness to put
your name on to an idea and publish it
that already sets you apart from the
crowd and disruptors while they're lone
wolves two-minute to some extent they
also find each other whether it's in the
cubicle next door or the building across
the way or even across the country
second been gathered them together to
really listen to their frustrations
rather than squash them one of the
phrases that really makes me angry is
when senior leaders say if you have a
problem don't tell it to me unless you
have a solution oftentimes junior people
have lots of problems they don't know
the solutions to and they need guidance
this is untapped energy that's just
waiting to be unleashed third then
rallied them around a common enemy in
this case middle managers you have this
mismatch between senior officers who
really intrude on today's e ideas with
those below them who had a mandate to
slow those things down
and if we didn't get their approval then
we just jumped ahead of them to their
senior who usually was in our favor and
you can use the bureaucracy against
itself in this sense because people will
always fall in line in Ben's view the
lasting impact of his work was in
demonstrating that this kind of
innovation could be fueled from the
bottom-up by black sheep inside the Navy
they planted seeds for dozens of other
rapid innovation cells across the
military and so for me the greatest
success is the mindset that it created
within a very bureaucratic organization
to take charge to empower people to run
with an idea and build a community of
support around that and do it regardless
of whether or not you had official
support all right as much as I love this
whole recipe I have one little problem
with it you can only use it once
if you succeed people aren't underdogs
anymore that was Brad Birds big
challenge when it came time to make a
sequel to The Incredibles this time the
team was stacked with hit makers there
was no common enemy
and they had three and a half years to
make the film it seems like it would
have been harder to frame the crew as
underdogs given how remarkably
successful the original movie was except
that they took a year off of our
schedule and suddenly were the underdogs
again we had a hell of a mountain to
climb that in many ways was taller than
our first one the studio asked us to
release the film a year earlier than
what we had originally planned a year is
a lot we tried to reestablish that
underdog theme and and taking a year off
the schedule sure helped that's one way
to turn superstars into under tux again
but to make it work the new challenge
has to be meaningful or exciting not
just an arbitrary burden you know
there's an attitude out there a bunch of
people with their arms folded like this
better be good you know which which
doesn't help inspire you to do anything
good you know but what is challenging is
can you take
a year off the schedule and still come
out with a great movie and come in on or
under budget and you know drop the mic
the team had the fuel they needed it
became a just manageable difficulty
Incredibles to grossed over a billion
dollars in its first two months alone
eclipsing the original film's total
theatrical revenues it was nominated for
an Oscar and won the People's Choice
Award for favorite family movie yes it's
it's cool for adults and kids that's
what a bunch of black sheep can do and
oh yeah it's now the highest-grossing
animated film in American history most
importantly it got six thumbs up from my
favorite experts what was the first
thing you said when we came out of the
theater I want to see it again and again
how many times have you seen it you've
seen it four times why cuz I like I
think it was twice in the same week
work life is hosted by me Adam grant the
show is produced by Ted with transmitter
media our team includes Colin Helms
Greta cone
Jessica Glaser grace Rubenstein Angela
Chang and Janet Leigh this episode was
produced by dan O'Donnell our show is
mixed by Rick Kwan original music by
Hans dal-su and Alison Layton Brown add
stories produced by pineapple street
media special thanks to our sponsors
bonobos Accenture Hilton and JPMorgan
Chase thanks to Bob Sutton for alerting
us to the incredible story and Jamie
wolf Chris Wiggum Rick Sayer Alan barrel
arrow and Greg Brando for sharing their
perspectives and helping with interviews
at Pixar as well as rich Walsh in the
military for their research Jing Chou
and Jennifer George and dissatisfaction
fueling creativity Simsek cannon
colleagues on stretch goals and Jane
dutton and Bob Duncan on the fat cat
syndrome next time on work life we
finished and I hear sheelane go it was
hard I taste the blood and then she
doesn't so awesome I was like you know
what I'm gonna find out exactly what I'm
made of sure Olympic rivals and pretty
good friends too
we'll explore how to get the best of
both worlds
[Music]
people beat daddy I'm in your studio
let's push but end is La Vie careful
I regret and I have no hair as iPod
Touch is great